he shouldn't be crying Boys Don't Cry
and what that turns into I see it when
now be a woman cry like women I mean it
was an entitlement and that's toxic
masculinity it's saying like if I have
to consider what I wear before stepping
up the house because I don't want
oh my God why didn't you let me on this
panel I would have started freaking out
right there what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to my reaction series today we
are going to be reacting to a jubilee
video on toxic masculinity but before I
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
the way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos like the video on your
way in let's get started
um so today's video is about toxic
masculinity all these toxically
masculine men they had a debate Pro
versus con toxic Mass masculinity pull
up the clip King I think that toxic
masculinity is definitely a real thing
it's kind of just the idea of what
masculinity should be but it goes wrong
a lot of the time translation I want to
determine what masculinity is as a woman
let me decide for you man saying that
violence sex power being a controlling
person makes you a man I see it in very
unfortunate where where is this like
idea that violent sex and power is
promoted as being a man because I I damn
near I don't see it anywhere guys I
seriously don't now now you could say in
history maybe that was the outcome but
like this idea that in the media uh this
is pushed get out of here
um yeah but the reality is violence what
do you say violent sex power and power
are actually components of being a man
yeah I know you like it well I'm saying
like that like she's acting like they
push this they push the opposite they
try to make men into women it's like do
you want a violent guy do you want a guy
a boyfriend that can't beat anybody up
is that ideal for you oh no no they
probably would say yes that's the crazy
thing it's probably just to like feed
into this delusion they would say yes I
don't want a boyfriend that can beat
anyone up this is like when the young
men or boys in my family even from like
toddler age or told you shouldn't be
crying Boys Don't Cry and what that
turns into I see it when now be a woman
cry like women I'm in a bookstore and a
guy who tries to get my number says why
y'all always got to act like that and
he's sincerely are men really like
asking for your number like that okay
I'm not trying to have this like
cracking voice like he was hurt but it
was an entitlement and that's toxic
masculinity it's saying like you don't
realize how your behavior is well maybe
you were being rude lady like you know
what this says like when women tell me
stories like this it's like usually she
rejected him in like a mean way and
that's why he's like you don't gotta be
like that
I mean
what does toxic masculinity mean is it
character traits is it upbringing the
suppression of feeling for a lot of men
because throughout childhood they're
told man up so because of that there's a
lot of repression repression then is
usually channeled into anger for some
people because they don't not always
know how to express because they're told
not to express so upbringing and that's
part of it yes but not something that's
inherently a part of no of men no I
think that we if expressing yourself and
expressing your feelings and always
crying is such a good thing why are
there still so many shitty women like if
because women keep saying men need to
express more like be in their feelings
and that's typically what women do so if
that is such a good thing that men need
to do so how come there's still so many
shitty women that do all those things
showing your emotions especially to like
you know random people
um random women in some cases they will
view you as weak I was raised by a
single mother I love her she's you know
she's my mom I love her but I'm shocked
who's raised by a single mother shocked
could have used being told to to act
actually what percent of this panel you
think was raised by single moms I bet
you uh 70 I think back there were some
cases where I was too emotional and that
negatively affected how I uh you know
what happened to me you might ask a
question sure what is your definition of
weak as a man
they invite me to me did that I should
have gotten an invitation to this
I absolutely need an invitation just
imagine me sitting there smiling in my
pink dress I'm ready to contribute guys
you think they would have welcomed me
yeah I I think that I need an invite
um not being as forward as you could be
not being is uh
um honest or you know trying to be not
as emotional as you don't need to be you
know you don't have to cry over a cut I
know you know sometimes cuts hurt a lot
but sometimes it's necessary to be
strong for the benefit of not just
yourself but for the people around you
you know it's fine to to act emotional
in certain cases but I don't think it's
fine to act that way with a woman uh
maybe you know you have a really good
friend and he sees you cry like you know
he's your best I think men should
basically be emotionless in front of
women because otherwise we'll just use
it use your emotion to control you yeah
I would just
not bring the emotion to women keep that
away and you're crying about something
really personal
um I think that's fine I feel like
you're conflating two different
situations because you started off with
saying random person or even women so it
feels like okay this is a woman that you
don't have a bond with or any type of
uh relationship with and then you
mentioned or in front of your best
friend you know that's okay to cry well
that woman could be your best friend
that you know like so and again so
because you don't see us as equal as you
said before I see if I was there I would
say yes men are better than us better
as a collective better not equal we
cannot be equal
how can you be equal when you have to
ask that group to give you rights that
would imply that you have to go up and
at like if you ask your boss for a raise
you still have to ask your boss you have
to ask men for rights like we wouldn't
have any rights if men didn't impose
them the crazy thing is the reality is
women don't even see each other's equals
neither do men men don't see each other
as equals but for some reason we have to
see like men have to see women as equals
and women have to see men as equals yeah
who's equal
thing showing emotions is a sign of
weakness I actually thinks it's a sign
of strength men do live shorter lives
and that's because of a repression of
emotions and that students she clearly
has never read 48 Laws of Power and what
about like dangerous jobs
she said they have shorter lives because
they repress emotions what is that from
probably some feminist
Professor that made up a study many
things that patriarchy has instilled
emotions it has been shown that a
person's well-being their life span is
shortened when they are not able to
express their emotions in addition when
they don't have physical well then we
have to Define what is expressing
emotions like this is the thing like
they make these studies with these broad
words that you can use to define goddamn
anything and then boom there's my study
what she meant to say is Express their
emotions the way women do a man a man
can express his emotions by punching
another person that's an expression of
emotion yeah or punching a wall punching
a wall or punching a boxing bag or I
don't know lifting weights there are so
many ways to express your emotions you
don't have to cry or when they don't
have a partner to keep them company
we're human beings here we need to talk
to each other and if you think that our
health isn't affected when you're not
able to express that you are sad or
upset you're wrong
I think that men's rights activists are
only men's rights activists as a
response to women expressing that they
want more quality I don't think they
focus on actual men's rights issues and
rather it's just an attack on women and
feminism
today women have more advantages than
men
I can speak from a hiring standpoint on
when it comes to things like affirmative
action and there are certain roles that
that
traditionally men and women have been
able to serve in and now women can
basically do all of those things right
because we've had such a strong advocacy
for equal representation in the
workplace whereas for example you know
you'll never find a man as a midwife
nurse and I don't think it's appropriate
that's why there are those differences
women in like the most important parts
of society have an advantage there's a
lot of positions that men simply aren't
getting hired at anymore because of you
know the fact that they're a man and
it's not just in in in in the workforce
it's also I would say you know it's a
lot easier for a woman to to find a
relationship even if she you know says
it's us finding the right guy is so hard
it really isn't but uh find sometimes
for a lot of guys finding a girl at all
is hard
if I have to consider what I wear before
stepping out the house because I don't
want
oh my God why didn't you let me on this
panel I would have started freaking out
right there I would have I would have
brought the temperature up in the room I
know they want these soft convos no this
is a debate Pearl's here look it oh boo
hoo you have to consider what you wear
before stepping out can men just wear
Speedos no but women can damn near dress
like go to work and if anyone says
anything it's discrimination they can
require that men wear a suit if in a
finance job or whatever it is a polo but
oh if they say hey can you please not
dress like a hooker the women will whine
and cry and say oh I have to consider
what I wear men have always had to
consider what they wear do you have you
seen the shoes that used to be required
to wear to work like the business shoes
they would literally be so tight and
small it would like change the shape of
their foot like it's so if you look at
the ones from like 50 100 years ago and
companies are more lacks on these
policies now but seriously
you're big outcry is you had to consider
what you had to wear oh my gosh you draw
some type of attention I don't know how
many other men have to consider it's
just every man every single man deemed
safe for me any situations I have
experienced every person has to consider
what they wear
like I physically felt endangered
simply because I don't want to give my
number out okay but you felt endangered
but were you endangered
that's the question part of that
entitlement for men you're not entitled
a conversation with me you're not
entitled to my number that aside like
okay I'm not even trying to be rude are
men like really checking like that like
these women they're fine looking but
like can we stop pretending like that
they're the hottest piece of ass walking
around and there's just like men lined
up out the door asking for your number
like men don't even really approach that
much in general and you're telling me
all of these men are just saying please
lady please like this like I'm not
saying she's ugly so don't don't confuse
this but like is she nah she's not the
one she's not the one she's not the one
that's getting all these truckloads of
men disturbing her nah she's not the one
yeah like she's
it's like
um you're not entitled to a conversation
with me I mean okay but maybe it
depending on what she wears
maybe if she's getting all this
truckload of attention then we should
actually ask what is she actually
wearing
I mean I'm just my whole thing is men
don't even really approach that much
anymore anyways let's just stop
pretending that you just have this line
of men just dying to date you nobody
wants to talk to I mean and let's be
honest you men want to talk to us that
much anyway
they're trying to they're trying to F
you know what I mean they're not trying
to talk they're just trying to you know
a conversation when you're not entitled
to my number that aside
it's like are you gonna do you hear him
like it's so funny this guy's kind of
based and you could see him being like
uh-huh right and then he's like all
right one example of the entitlement of
men when it comes to asking for your
number be the all-encompassing thing
that all men have a problem when it
comes to approaching women well firstly
it's not just an example it's not
necessarily all men I don't dislike men
I love sports oh my God if you have to
say I don't dislike men games I have
Bros I hang out with dudes we just want
men to realize that if you have friends
that are having locker room talk as a
man as an ally do you hear this do you
hear this you cannot have like all right
all right ladies let's stop who talks
more to the opposite gender about our
relationship lives or sorry sorry who
talks more to our gender about their
relationship lives like do women talk to
their female friends more about their
boyfriend or do the boyfriend talk to
their male friends about their
girlfriend more who does what I mean
let's just call it what it is we have
locker room talk like come on it's like
women just have this need to like police
men's spaces on what they can say about
us please say something to your friends
do you think repressing that is really
the solution here though if it's in a
healthy male space I don't think that's
healthy I think it's time I mean if
you're making jokes and you're doing all
that jokes that are harmful jokes are
not healthy because they just lead to
people normalizing things people always
say oh it's just a joke but when someone
else hears it they don't realize how
that resonates and again how that turns
into violence like this is not an
isolated situation I'm only thinking of
three off the top of my head because if
I think of too many it's gonna I'm gonna
spiral so what's the alternative men
shouldn't talk about these things no I
think men can have a healthy dialogue I
don't think men have to be toxic in
order to have a conversation I know
plenty of men that are able to have
conversations about healthy productive
productive things just like women are
well it's not obviously something that I
have personal experience with but only
one percent of all people on the death
row are women in this country Southern
women and men commit identical crimes
women are much more likely to for
example escape the death penalty and
that's just plain sex based
discrimination
that I agree on that's true look I'm
thinking about basic needs like around
the globe the women who don't even have
like proper like sanitary like products
do men have proper Sanitary products
like oh my gosh I get my period And I
don't get free tampons shut up I mean I
have to agree it's a small of course you
agree
thanks like attacks on a box of tampons
do you think I choose to to do this
monthly and I'm sorry there are tampon
Pro like you could buy the what about
the tax on me bossing or not do you
think I I choose to want to bust a nut
every single day I wake up but then if I
want to bust or not I have to part with
money bro like the things people
complain about is so like it's just
weird yeah well and I'm like well I'm
just thinking you can buy there's like
certain women products you can buy once
and like I won't get into it but like
you don't have to buy tampons that's my
only like there's other stuff so it's
like what
there's actually so many options like
lady what are you no trust me so why
should I have to pay taxes when this is
a medical necessity it would just like
dismissed a lot of our symptoms a lot of
the things we report
I mean
what about the man on child support what
about I wish they had me on this panel
oh my God I wish that why don't you guys
invite me I should have been invited
especially women of colorful women
across the board are just treated a lot
less equally
you see the face of the Asian guy say
that I'm an advocate for what I believe
the role that men play in society I
believe that their views should be
expressed openly that they should be
given a platform to do so and I believed
in men
unapologetically and unashamedly being
men as we were created
I think in my heart that there are
things that men are entitled to I am all
about human rights and I try to consider
I do consider the rights of every human
but um ah
you know it's crazy feminists about
equality but haven't mentioned one men's
issue we're talking about toxic
masculinity you know so funny they made
it about us the whole time that part of
the convo is about toxic masculinity and
we somehow found a way to make something
that the feminists advocate for men for
about us that's crazy every time I hear
of a men's rights activist I hear anger
and I hear very illogical reasoning and
it just boils my blood because it's a
setback for all of us lady let's let's
talk some logic let's talk some some
logic you know men are better at
everything except me at karaoke but
seriously guys this level of delusion
like I'm so tired of like average chicks
acting like people are checking you for
you like that look I'm an average chick
if I want to go out you know the only
time people like it's like if they're
coming to get pictures or whatever but
if I really don't want people to notice
me I just put on a hoodie and sweats no
one will know who I am it's like this
idea that they just oh we're just
chasing you down it's like okay then
where where a sweatsuit oh the metal
just like you hear the girls in the show
Oh They'll Come and find me anyway I'm
like really will they like all right but
maybe I'm crazy I don't know
um if you know any of the crazy
feminists in this video DM them tell
them let's stream let's talk about these
crazy ideas like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel I'll talk
to you next time